You've made it to the end of this course on world building for virtual production.
Congratulations!
And thank you for being part of this class.
Let's take a moment to review what we learned in the past lessons.
First of all, we learned about the concept of derived data cache and how Unreal makes
use of it.
We explored workflows to assess scope when developing our environments for virtual production
and reviewed how to import external assets into our seeds.
Further on, we also got a quick overview on basic lighting, editing assets, materials,
foliage, and profiling.
Lots of small bytes of information there, but hopefully they helped you get an overall
idea over where things are in the engine and how to use them.
Thank you again for sticking around.
I really hope you enjoyed this course and learned a few tricks from it.
You're welcome to take a look at the other courses on our platform.
Prefer to expand your understanding of the engine.
Now I wish you lots of fun building some crazy worlds in Unreal that I can't wait to
see and I'll see you soon.
Bye!